distinguished guests commissioner
ferreira
dear colleagues
millions of ukrainians are seeking
shelter in the european union
torn from their families and country by
putin's bombs
the scenes of war are devastating
but the images of european citizens
welcoming refugees show another picture
they show hope
ukraine and the european union have
never been closer
until ukrainians can safely return home
and rebuild their independent and
democratic country in peace
we will welcome and support them
because they are part of our european
family
and this is why last week
the european commission put forward care
this package of cohesion action for
refugees
makes cohesion funds available for
member states
this will help them to build reception
centers for example mobile hospitals and
schooling for children
but it can also provide employment
support for example training and
language courses or child care
facilities
care will help member states to welcome
ukrainian refugees quickly and humanely
and for me this is a truly inspiring
example
because it shows what a difference
cohesion policy can make
both as a short-term response to crisis
and a long-term investment in democratic
resilience
and the good thing is
there are so many examples like these
everywhere in our union
from our pandemic response for example
where cohesion funds supplied
ventilators hospital beds and medical
equipment
but also to the green transition
they all demonstrate the impact of
cohesion policy in the everyday lives of
europeans
we all know the great strength of
cohesion
first
it's pure power because cohesion comes
with impressive financial backing
we're talking about nearly 400 billion
euros from 2021 to 2027
with an
estimated 100 billion on top from member
states
but this is not all
cohesion policy is so powerful first and
foremost
because it delivers on a core promise of
our union
that all regions are equal
that european citizens no matter where
can live
safe and prosperous lives
this promise brings us here today
i'm grateful to be able to address this
cohesion forum
because today we need cohesion policy
more than ever
and that brings me to the second
strength
cohesion is a driver of change
as you know europe stands at the
beginning of a new transformation
we want to become the first climate
neutral continent by 2050.
and all across europe citizens have
started on their way
to a net zero future
they want to live in greener cities
and breathe fresh air
and they want to have a real choice
between working for example in the city
or the countryside
cohesion policy will help to make this
transformation happen
just remember the
1970s back then
money from cohesion funds supported
european coal and industrial regions
in their necessary transformation
where coal was once mined we built
universities and science centers
this attracted talent and with talent
came innovation
new roads and airports connected towns
and businesses across the single market
many of these regions became globally
competitive
cohesion policy has done it before
and we will do it again
this time cohesion policy supports
regions in another transformation
on their way to a greener and more
sustainable future
this transformation starts in every
village every town every region
together we will invest in renewables
like never before
we will increase connectivity
be it with railways or be a digital
we will help smes to develop
cutting-edge technology
and we will make europe's regions more
resilient
and revive their natural beauty
the third strength
cohesion is a safeguard of social
balance
both the green and the digital
transition will only work for people and
businesses
when it is just
i cannot stress this point enough
everybody must be able to benefit from
this transformation
here
cohesion policy will do what it does
best
because we know that some regions have a
longer way to a net zero future than
others
and this is why with the just transition
fund
we are just helping those regions shift
away from carbon heavy industries
you have all heard about our european
green deal
and behind all of its proposals
there is an opportunity for local
entrepreneurs
local businesses have already started to
create
the new clean economy that will make
europe the innovation continent and the
best place to live and work
and with the support of the regional
development and social plus funds
we will make sure
that our citizens have the skills to
benefit from this
cohesion makes education and lifelong
training possible for all european
citizens
and finally
the fourth strength
cohesion is a true multiplier
studies demonstrate this time and again
two-thirds of the cohesion funds
go to the least developed regions in
europe
and returns are nearly three times the
initial investments
this is a rate of return no bank and no
equity portfolio can offer
this demonstrates the simple
timeless truth
behind cohesion policy
when the less developed regions are
doing better
we will all do better
and this is why cohesion policy is such
a vital ingredient of our unique single
market
it empowers regions
the silent engines of europe's growth
cohesion is a true european success
story
but there's still work to do and we all
know this
so let me make two short proposals
first
go local
local stakeholders mayors and regional
administrators they know best what
citizens need on the ground
so we should put them even more into the
center of our decision making
and involve them at every step
from drafting regional and national
plans
to their implementation on the ground
local stakeholders must think
where they want their region to be in 10
years
and build their own plan towards the
future
this links to my second message
speed up
because at the moment
there is a significant delay in cohesion
programming
money from the new european budget
should already be paid to projects but
regional plans are still missing
this is due to the pandemic of course
but nevertheless
we have to catch up
and this is why i call on all
governments to speed up their
programming
to accelerate
the take up of the new cohesion funds
i call on them to devote all their
efforts and resources to getting the
projects going
and my commission will help with
technical assistance where needed
because we want every region in europe
to emerge stronger from the pandemic
greener more digital and more resilient
and we want this to happen as soon as
possible
and this is where next generation eu
comes into play our 800 billion euro
recovery program
cohesion policy and next generation eu
can complement each other
like in valencia in spain
where there is a biomedical research
institute that has the capability to do
gene sequencing
this helps us to control the emergence
of new variants
and be one step ahead of the virus
cohesion funds help the lab increase its
testing capacity seven fold
and next generation eu helps spain to
digitalize its entire health sector
both three forms fit together seamlessly
and we need more of this
ladies and gentlemen
cohesion policy really creates big
headlines
but there is simply no better example
for what i call
the silent strength of our union
the promise
that we all enjoy the fruits that come
from peace and progress
that no region or community is left
behind
because we invest in our future together
this makes our towns and regions prosper
cohesion policy
is the instrument of choice for all
regions to reap the benefits
of our new european growth model
because in europe
we pull each other up
this is our strength
this is the european way
and i cannot end here without thanking
those who make this all possible
local and regional authorities
city associations and mayors small
enterprises and ngos from across our
union
your work
has a direct positive impact on the
everyday lives of european citizens
you make european funds count in cities
and villages everywhere in our union
thank you very much